foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
we thank you for joining us and for
being part of this question and answer
program where we get the privilege of
answering your questions from the word
of God and we always make it that
promise that when we undertake to answer
your questions those answers will come
from the word of God we feel here at six
unsail and some TV it's a little late in
the history of this Earth to be dealing
with the questions or the answers that
come from the brains of men we're not
really smart enough to answer all of the
questions that that come but God is and
he's left the answers in his word so we
make it that promise we will come from
the word of God and if an answer can be
found in the word of God we will find
that answer and bring it to you I'm in
the company of two fellow Travelers on
the road to glory the fellow students of
the word to my left Pastor Stephen Bohr
president of seekers uncertain some TV
and to my right Pastor David Salazar who
is the general manager of of our Latino
Channel both of these men doing a fine
job working for the Lord
one for many many years one for several
years and I I'm I fall sort of in
between actually I'm closer to you than
I am to David uh but we have a good time
uh with this program because we like to
study the word of God Amen we want to
encourage you to get in on the fun to be
part of our experience by sending your
questions to TV at some
tv.org that is TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org and we will get to your
questions just as fast as we can we are
sort of pleased to know
that questions are coming in from all
over the world that means that our
footprint is spanning the globe but it
also means that men and women are being
blessed by watching some TV and that
pleases us and we we know it pleases the
Lord because he is the author and
finisher of our faith and the author of
this particular Ministry and so we like
to get the questions because the
questions let us know that what we're
doing what we are sending out is being
consumed and is being a blessing to you
the viewer and The Listener that's why
we ask you when you send in your
questions let us know where you're
writing from so that we get an idea of
where our footprint is and how God is
spreading the message throughout the
world gentlemen this is a good program
we've got some good questions you know
sometimes when we take questions some
questions are very heavy very
theological very serious some questions
a little bit lighter you know they're
not all earth-shattering questions but
they do mean something to the person
sending in the question amen which is
why we want to take time with them and
not Overlook anyone because all of the
questions are important to us because
they are important to you Pastor board
if you would offer prayer we will begin
and start with our first question which
is coming to us from South Africa okay
before that I just want to mention the
reason why we do this program not live
uh you know the reason why is because
when you get a question live
you know you just basically uh answer
off the top of your head
this gives us an opportunity to do
research to answer the question fully
and completely that's why sometimes we
take a whole program to answer one
question or two programs to answer one
question correct so that's the reason
why we do not take live uh questions so
we can do the research and give an
informed answer let's pray Father in
heaven we thank you so much for the
privilege of participating in this
program what a blessing it is to do
research to find answers to the very
important questions that are sent to us
I ask Lord that you will give us Divine
wisdom that you will give us Clarity of
thought that we might answer these
questions in harmony with your will and
we thank you for the promise of your
presence and with those who will watch
the program we pray in Jesus name amen
amen amen and amen our first question
comes from
it is either I may or email that letter
i in some languages is pronounced I in
other languages it is pronounced e so it
could be IMA it could be email and he is
running from South Africa pastor would
you read that question for us sure it
has actually two parts to the question
so the first uh part of the question is
in regards to the keeping of a few
chickens in the farm they have a small
farm and the question is if they can
take I will I'll read it but it's uh
just make it a short uh you know consist
as possible it says it's the wrong to
take food for these chickens out to them
on the Sabbath
and if we don't take food they will have
to fast all day on Sabbath moreover or
on one needs to open the house so that
the chickens can go out and walk and
about and enjoy some outdoors so the
first question is regards to the
chickens that they have in the farm and
whether or not it's okay to feed them
and allow them to leave their Coop you
know coming in and out and roam the
Sabbath so that's the first question and
second question is in regards to some
young puppies they have some small dogs
I suppose and unfortunately they as
they're young they eat and they uh you
know poo at the end of the you know
whatever happens so it says that they
pull all over the place and for whatever
reason uh they like to do it in front of
the house so the question is can they
clean after this poopy puppies uh you
know do their business and is it okay to
do it on the Sabbath you know it's
difficult to find the terms
so the question is you know and I
believe that you know the person is
Syrian obviously wants to make sure that
they're not transgressing the Sabbath by
doing things that are not supposed to do
so the two questions are kind of related
but that's what the question is so
gentlemen how do we answer this question
you know I think that we can answer this
question with the Bible but first of all
the Bible when it speaks about Sabbath
observance speaks in principles right it
doesn't give a long list of do's and a
long list of don'ts in other words we
have in our communion with God
we have to be sincere in asking is this
proper to do on the Sabbath right now
with regards to animals the Bible has
principles that are very very clear for
example we have in the book of Exodus
chapter 23 verse 12 the Sabbath wasn't
made only for man to rest it was made
for Beast to rest as well and I can't
think that the chickens are resting very
well in the coop all day right so it
says here in chapter 3 23 and verse 12
six days you shall do your work and on
the seventh day you shall rest that your
ox and your donkey May rest and the son
of your female servant and the stranger
may be refreshed so in other words the
animals are supposed to enjoy arrest on
the Sabbath as well which means that we
need to be concerned about animals on
the Sabbath indeed the other example is
in the New Testament Matthew chapter 12
and verses 10 through 12. you know what
would you do do for example if a sheep
falls into a pit on the Sabbath you say
well tough luck it's the Sabbath stay
there all day Sabbath right no Jesus
made it clear that out of Mercy for the
animal you would take it out even the
Pharisees would right it says there in
chapter 12 and verses 10 through 12
maybe somebody could read that for me
Matthew chapter 12 10-12 those are the
texts that I I had cited myself of in
Matthew chapter 12 and I'm back up to
verse 10 and we are reading at verse 9
and 10 and behold there was a man
who had a withered hand and they asked
him saying is it lawful to heal on the
Sabbath that they might accuse him so
their most harassing question we're not
we're not genuine uh then he said to
them
what man is there among you who has one
Chief if it falls into the pit on the
Sabbath will not lay a hold of it and
lift it out of how much more value than
is a man than a sheep therefore it is
lawful to do good on the Sabbath so if
you relieve a sheep
from being in a pit all day Sabbath
you know isn't a human being more
important that he be delivered right
from bondage to a withered hand
the Sabbath is a day of delight and then
if you read verses 1 and 2 the disciples
and Jesus were going through a field on
the Sabbath
and the disciples took some of the Grain
and were eating on the Sabbath you know
would God want people to go hungry on
the Sabbath no he gave them Anna on
Friday twice as much so you could eat on
Sabbath the Jews don't fast on Sabbath
because the Sabbath is not a day for
fasting it's a day for celebration for
feasting in the right sense of the word
so we need to think in principles and
and we need to care for the needs of
animals I'm sure that God doesn't want
us to leave what the animals do on on
Sabbath there to get full of flies and
to contaminate the environment we have
to be practical in our way of thinking
that's right Pastor I also think that
the part of the way that we need to
understand is that
God does not want us to do things that
could have been done in another day of
the week right I mean you know the
Sabbath is uh uh a day of rest as you
will mentioned so no labor no work that
can be done in the other day of the week
no Duty that can be done another day of
the week but taking care of animals
feeding them cleaning them it's it has
to be done on Sabbath right it should be
done yeah it's pretty prophecy says that
actually in um you know in the book
someone's for the church volume six page
3 54.
she says no Duty pertaining to the six
working days will be left for the
Sabbath so in other words nothing that
can be done in another day should be
done in Summit but if the Sabbath needs
to be done something that cannot be you
know postponed has to be done you know
simple as that so use that principle to
to select what can be done and we cannot
be done you can't hit uh Sabbath food on
Friday exactly you can't that
of course
but right through some people
some people that that's that's you know
doing the wrong because there's a very
thin line between obedience and legalism
right you know if you're always looking
well is this proper is that proper is
the other thing proper uh you know that
would be a legalistic approach if we're
close to Jesus we our own conscience
will tell us what is proper and what is
not impr what is not proper on Sabbath
uh so God gives us a mind to think right
and to reason correct uh and then we
make a decision based on that yeah
absolutely it is it is lawful to do good
to relieve suffering on on the Sabbath
let me give you a very practical example
years ago when I was public of Harris
and religious liberty leader for the
conference in New York City there was an
incredibly huge snowstorm it lasted from
Thursday night right up until Sabbath
morning
and um they called all hands on deck
which meant everybody who works for the
city had to come in because this is a
crippling snowstorm and there were
several Adventists who didn't come they
didn't go
um
and I went with them to meet with the
magistrate to discuss uh
their status because they were about to
get fired and
um the the
they said well we don't work on Sabbath
and I said well I've got your papers I
know you don't you've never worked on
Sabbath he said but we we feel this is a
different thing he said ambulances need
to get through
fire trucks need to get through
this is a special kind of thing because
the city is crippled and we need to open
up this city because we're too big of a
city to to shut down
and they said well we we just don't we
don't we don't work on Sabbath then he
asked this question
he said
if it snows on Friday night do you
shovel the walks in front of your church
on seven
or do you let fog go slipping and
sliding into into into church well the
Lord will keep them from falling
no they will as far as the snow storm
yeah you should remove the snow before
it starts snowing
I'm being facetious
humor today you know you know it could
be but but he has that question it was
don't you shovel the walk in front of
your truck of course you do first of all
it's a city law to do so sure and if
someone slips in front of your church uh
on ice or snow then they will end up
owning your church because you're
supposed you're supposed to do that
right uh and and so they thought about
that now we we sort of massage the
situation they didn't lose their job but
they didn't lose some pay uh because he
said I know you you you you I've been to
Adventist churches
um and I know that you shovel your walks
in front of church I remember when I was
on the general conference committee they
dealt with with um
working in hospitals Adventist hospitals
on Sabbath Adventist hospitals don't
shut down on Sabbath people are fed
people are cared for
elective surgeries are put off till
after Sabbath right surgeries that have
to take place and someone comes into the
emergency room that person is is seen to
so it it the text of Matthew 12 12 it is
lawful to do good on the Sabbath to
relieve suffering on the Sabbath last
example my first Elders house caught on
fire on Friday night and burned almost
to the ground
we canceled church and we went and
helped him
recover what was left you know we're
digging through ashes and we spent the
whole Sabbath day the neighbors watched
us and uh were very impressed uh he said
this is my church you know he was happy
but this is my church helping me out we
did that on the Sabbath uh because he
had nowhere to go no to turn he was
trying to recover what he could and
thieves are going to break in and not
break in but just take whatever was left
so he wanted to help him as best we
could and the time to do it was sacred
Arts I felt that was a just thing to do
yeah don't you think though that
um in the case of the snowstorm
where the snow needs to be cleared don't
you think that the people of the church
who do that should dedicate the money
that they make that day to charitable
purposes or else that would be working
for profit yeah that would be a very
good thing to do so it applies to
hospital workers nurses doctors they
should set aside that money for
charitable purposes and not profit from
it yes yes you you know you've got
you've got to be wise and one of the
things that the Lord gives us as we walk
with him is discernment you know you can
think your way things through things we
had a number of cats that were given to
us well we had one cat
uh and another cat was given to us we
thought they were two females we found
out months later they were not two
females so we had a bunch of cats
um invariably these cats would dig up
moles and and present them at our front
door on Sabbath morning
almost every Sabbath morning we could
look for a little gift at our front door
charitable donation little yeah because
we certainly didn't request it but they
would just present this dead mole on the
on the stoop on so you have to accept it
right now we're not gonna leave that
yeah you know you you've got to be wise
about those things so you don't want
your animals to suffer uh last one I had
an elder first Elder who raised I was
telling Pastor Salazar who who had um
dairy cows and those cows had to be
milked every morning he said they
suffered greatly if they were not milked
right and he had to do it sometimes he
could put it off till the afternoon he'd
have to duck out of church very quick
because he had to milk those cows well
you know you don't want your animals to
suffer God takes care of them and he
takes care of humans also so be wise
pray about it be sincere and God will
lead you in the right way because he
always does good amen
already Pastor board do you have the
second question this one is coming to us
we don't have a location this is from
Maria
de Chiara Chiara
yeah I don't know uh where where this
person would be from but uh the question
is short dear Pastor Bohr and of course
those who are on the panel
uh could you advise me about organ
donations should Christians do it
so basically that's a question how about
organ donation should we donate our
organs uh you know in your driver's
license sometimes they'll put whether
you're willing to donate your organs
what can we say about that
I suppose there is not a a Biblical
answer necessarily that I couldn't
really feel that could really answer
this question uh directly from the Bible
as it's more of a principle as possible
was mentioning you know the principle of
doing good to others and I think that
science has come a long ways and
in a sense you know when somebody is
loses their life donating the organs is
a way that you can support and help
someone else that is coming along but I
think there's a you know kind of a
divided view on this idea I've heard
some brothers and sisters who are very
much against this concept of donating
organs uh I think it's more of an
individual decision that I think should
be supported whether one way or the
other I see the point that people feel
it's okay to do good if if the Lord you
know causes them to die or to pass away
for their organs to be donated to
someone else I don't see nothing wrong
with that and then there's some some who
have feel that is not ethically correct
to do this yeah and I don't per se you
know I want to persuade somebody to do
things otherwise so I believe this is a
question that it comes down to how the
Holy Spirit really impresses you to to
see this as whether or not it's
something you want to do or not but I I
really cannot tell you from a from a I
couldn't find it perhaps Professor code
for that even have you guys found
anything well the way I look at it is uh
in two ways first of all from the
perspective of the second coming of
Christ
and secondly there's another uh practice
that is related to this which is
cremation
of course we've worked together for a
long time but you know cremation is very
uh related to this idea now
if when you die
you can save the life of someone else
that's an act of love right right well
said now that's one point the second
point is
that when we resurrect
none of our old organs are going to be
giving us again and of course that's
that the matter that that we will be
composed of will be different let me
just read you a statement from from the
writings of Ellen White uh this is in
the book Heaven page 40. our personal
identity is preserved in the
resurrection though not the same
particles of matter or material
substance as went into the grave we're
not going to get the same kidney kidneys
and the same liver and the same heart
with the same matter that we had while
we were in this world right she
continues God does save something not
the organs but notice the wondrous works
of God are a mystery to man The Spirit
the character of man is returned to God
there to be preserved amen so it's not
the body parts it's our character or our
life record she continues in the
resurrection every man will have his own
character
not his own organs God in his own time
will call forth the dead giving again
the breath of life and bidding the dry
bones live the same form will come forth
but it will be free from disease and
every defect it lives again bearing the
same individuality of features so that
friend will recognize friend there is no
law of God in nature which shows that
God gives back the same identical
Partners particles of matter which
compose the body before death God shall
give the righteous dead a body that will
please him now before I read another
statement let me just mention I agree
with you that it's a matter of
conscience yes if your conscience says
don't do it follow what your conscience
says but morally in the light of the
Bible and the spirit of Prophecy I don't
see any objection to it but people need
to make the choice whether they're going
to do it or not correct now in another
place this manuscript 76 1900 Ellen
White wrote
Paul illustrates this subject which is
the statement that I just read
by the kernel of grain sown in the field
the planted kernel delays but there
comes forth a new kernel the natural
substance in the grain decays the the
natural substance in the grain that
decays is never raised as before but God
giveth the body as it hath pleased him
and I love this a much finer material
yeah yes will compose the human body for
it is a new creation a new birth it is
sown a natural body it is raised a
spiritual body amen so morally in the
light of the Bible the spirit of
Prophecy I don't see anything wrong with
uh cremation
after all God's not going to take the
same dust right that you're turned into
to make your new body and I don't see
any problem either right with the issue
of donating organs other than being
charitable and helping somebody else to
live and somebody else to be healthy
well said I don't know if you all agree
with it it's a strong man it is a straw
man because the the is it tougher for
God to put together a cremated body or
one that has dissolved naturally over
time
you know they're both but since you're
not using the original material you're
using a better model it doesn't matter
so it's a straw man you know I I have
two incidences I I wrote a article years
ago for the Atlanta union Gleaner of a
woman who was alive this was a a white
woman from upstate New York and she had
a black student young man from New York
City who was just in her class who did
just got along really well well his
kidneys fell she gave him one of hers
um his parents were in a match his
cousins were in a match no one was a
match and this woman totally different
race never knew him before except he was
a a student she was a teacher exact
match exact match so she gave it to him
you know while she was still alive and
last I heard they're both doing quite
well so if you can do it when you're
alive if you can help someone out why
not someone out white when you pass that
is a good thing and I see no biblical
injunction against it right yeah again
this could be you know if somebody has
an objection and maybe they are afraid
for reasons that could be matter of
conscience we can't really you know go
against that and they have to respect
that by the same time it's important
that like you said pastor that the
biblical uh guidelines tell us to do
good and if our bodies or parts or
organs you know can help someone else
you know I think it's a blessing I mean
if you think of people who have received
an extended extension of Life due to an
organ being donated or received you know
been recipient of one and how much the
love of lesson that is to their families
you can see why there's a there is a
probably a bigger argument in favor of
that but you know I think I I agree with
you that people need to follow their
conscience for example uh you know we
were talking about Sabbath observance
right you know there are things that my
conscience tells me that are not wrong
on Sabbath they're not prescribed
directly in scripture or the spirit of
Prophecy
but if somebody else their conscience
bothers them and they say you know this
is not proper on Sabbath well they need
to follow what their Conscience Says so
there's nothing in the Bible against
organ donation no and there's nothing in
the Bible against cremation it's a
matter of whether in your conscience you
decide to do one thing or to do the
other thing but in the light of the
statement from the spirit of Prophecy
and in the light of of helping somebody
else with continued living quality life
I don't see any moral reason why we
should not be willing to donate organs
or to be creamy fact cremation is good
stewardship
[Laughter]
I never quite thought of it because a
funeral can cost you fifteen twenty
thousand dollars easily but cremation
could cost you maybe a couple of
thousand dollars so you're saving uh
probably
fourteen to twenty thousand eighteen
thousand dollars absolutely you know and
give the rest that you would have spent
to the church absolutely to the work of
God you know I've and I've heard very
very effervescent arguments over blood
transfusion you know there was those
Christians say well the life is in the
blood you shouldn't be transfusing blood
um when I had my open heart surgery I
had six bypasses I had to get blood from
some place I didn't have enough uh so
they they added blood and I'm fine so
you you've got to pray about these
things I remember Luther and Melanson
fought over if the Bible didn't
particularly said you can't do it
forbid it you can do it and you know you
can get very caught up in these things
uh that are really peripheral one of the
things we should do is pray our way
through every decision
if you're going to sort of plant your
feet on it make sure you're doing God's
will as far as you know well the Bible
says in the book of Acts that we're all
made of one blood so if you give me of
your blood it's my blood too
[Laughter]
well said uh we don't really have time
to to go into another question you can
see that we like to take our time with
all of the questions and do do deference
to each one of them if you take the time
to write we want to take the time to
answer it thoroughly as we can from the
word of God everything does not have a
thus saith the Lord but if you pray and
ask God in sincerity then God will make
it plain to you because he has promised
to do this amen well our time has fast
slipped into eternity allowed me in
closing to wish you both Grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
we'll see you again soon bye bye and God
bless
[Music]
thank you
foreign